i want to thank nabb for this
opportunity to address you at the annual
meetings
are you passionate about plant breeding
i want to begin today by acknowledging
dr anne marie throw
the first napb friend of plant breeding
i found these quotes from anne marie in
an article honoring anne-marie's life of
service
it was posted online in december 2016
prior to her being selected for the
first friends of plant breeding award in
2017
i'm sure anne marie did not anticipate
her words would be shared here today
but they are perfect
as a model that she has set for us as
friends of plant breeding
anne marie said
i enjoy the role of taking the
initiative to look around
to see things that need to be done
and get started
often others join in and carry on the
work
anne-marie is passionate about plant
breeding
this is the role model for all napb
friends of plant breeding that is being
amplified here today for our emerging
plant breeders
look around
see the need
get started
others will join carry on the work
don't wait to get involved this approach
is great for all plant breeders and in
the pb members
it is a lesson that has been enshrined
in the career and legacy of dr norman
borlaug
he was another visionary plant breeder
and a doer he had a deep sense of
urgency compelling him to action
he had a passion for plant breeding
like anne marie dr borlaug passed on
that passion to others at every
opportunity he especially enjoyed
inspiring and encouraging emerging plant
breeders and hunger fighters
he counted on others to join in and
carry on the work
reflecting on her career anne marie said
i am grateful to have been able to bring
different researchers together into
networks and projects
this benefits science and the public by
creating opportunities to exchange good
ideas recruit young scientists and
search for funding
that is where i can help
as someone who understands the world of
science
seeks to be useful and enjoys creating
connections and
looking for opportunities
i think anne-marie's words
could have been written by dr borlaug
it is the same spirit the same passion
for plant breeding and for making the
world a better place
as a friend of plant breeding i share
anne-marie's views
i enjoy being useful
creating connections building
relationships looking for opportunities
to serve
the community
and acting on those visions
i love encouraging others to join in
and carry on the work i find they often
improve
what is being started
napb owes much gratitude to anne marie's
vision and hard work to help bring us
together as the national association of
plant breeders
i think anne marie would agree
that this is a wonderful feeling to be
recognized by your friends and
colleagues for having and sharing this
passion
for plant breeding
it is a great honor to be in the same
short list with anne marie
as a friend of plant breeding
plant-breeding passion
what is it
why is it important and where does it
come from
here are some statements about passion
for you to ponder
i love the word ponder i don't think we
do enough of it
passion is a strong desire that can get
you to do amazing things
passion can push you through difficult
times
because you don't care what it takes to
become better
passion is an emotion to be acted upon
without action passion yields no
worthwhile result
when you have passion for something you
love it even when you hate it
i'm not sure i know what that one means
i'll let you ponder that for yourself
finally
you can have all the passion in the
world for something but if you never do
anything about it
that passion
is useless
how do we relate plant breeding and
passion
what is plant breeding passion
plant breeding passion is a strong
desire to achieve results through new
cultivars
a thirst to be relevant
our cultivars must have impact
plant-breeding passion increases by
seeing the success of hybrids and
varieties that you helped to become
viable products
ones that have real impact and many
lives across the landscape
i like that we have an award two awards
now
recognizing noteworthy impact of plant
breeding
such awards show non-plant breeders the
importance of what we do
they demonstrate what exceptional plant
breeding passion looks like
for me plant-breeding passion includes
a sense of urgency
speed breeding shuttle breeding cycle
time genomic and phenomic selection
prediction
gene editing etc
it's sometimes described as fire in the
belly
indicating that it comes from deep
within
a strong work ethic
gitterton attitude
i can tell you plant breeding passion is
important because employers value it
hiring managers evaluated
selection committees discuss it prior to
the final hiring
i base this on my experience working
with many hiring managers and teams at
monsanto as global breeder sourcing lead
around the world they all wanted
candidates to show that they were
passionate about the breeding roles that
they were applying to
it is one of those intangibles
that can make the difference on who gets
the job offer
i think it's important because it
instills hope
in others who are working to solve
complex challenges where
improved plants can help us
i could not have been a successful plant
breeder without hope feeding my passion
teams function better
more gets done in less
time innovation is stimulated
success breeds success
plant breeding passion is highly
contagious
when nourished properly it encourages
others
breeders who have it
love what they do every day
plant-breeding passion typically comes
from experienced and influential people
people you trust
caring people
think about influential people like
beloved mentors who instilled the desire
for plant breeding in you
often
when meeting graduate students for the
first time i ask them
how did you become interested in plant
breeding
there was almost always an experienced
mentor
or influential person that made the big
difference
for them in choosing our profession
and pouring themselves into it so i like
to think relationships
are the soil
and encouragement is the fertilizer for
growing passion in plant breeders
initially it comes from others
think of your mentors
it gets internalized
and comes from it within
this does not happen overnight
external factors can shape it
population growth wars poverty and
starvation
and climate change
these drivers can have an impact
but i think
they are usually secondary to the
relationships that lead the way
like plants our passion in plant
breeding grows stronger over time
mentorship and awards programs change
lives
shown here in may of night of 2014
is a mentorship program known as the
hayes phillips lectureship and graduate
student award it was created 40 years
prior in 1974
through the vision of dr ron phillips at
the university of minnesota
i believe 2021 was the 48th year for
this program
perhaps some of you have benefited from
it
the longevity and success of the program
testifies to its success i can tell you
confidently that without this program
there likely would not be a borlaug
scholars travel grant
and mentoring program in napb today
ron phillips was not my advisor he was
not my on my graduate committee
he was however a trusted mentor in the
lab next door to the one i worked in he
cared about students i benefited from
that fact
in 1976 i received the third h k hayes
award
that year dr phillips invited
distinguished
alumnus dr norman borlaug
to be the invited speaker for this award
ceremony he also invited dr wayne kyme
i proudly include dr keim here because
without this purdue professor taking
interest in students i would not have
had a plant breeding career
you see
i had been admitted to dental school but
dr kyme made me a better offer
a career path in applied plant genetics
and plant breeding
i love dentists but it was an easy
choice for me i love plant breeding more
all of this brings me to the point
although i experienced a wonderful
career in private sector breeding corn
i never forgot the importance of public
plant breeders who encouraged and
enabled this career path
i didn't know this career existed
now back to my story
prior to the event dr phillips handed me
this copy of a book entitled campaigns
against hunger published in 1967.
three years prior to when dr borlaug
received the 1970 nobel peace prize
i graduated from high school in 1967 i
could relate to this book
dr phillips said i had to read it prior
to dr borlaug's arrival
he sent me to the pathology department
to meet with dr e c statement an
emeritus
professor
who was an author and editor dr stakeman
signed my book
ron prophetically told me that the book
would mean more to me later in life
he was right
in night in
2007 i had dr borlaug
signed the book just below dr stakeman's
signature
dr borlaug's granddaughter julie told me
that it was an emotional experience
bringing back a flood of memories for dr
borlaug seeing his mentor's signature
after more than 30 years
this mentoring program created by dr
phillips
accelerated the growing plant-breeding
passion within me
it was the encouragement i needed at the
right time
i love the picture on the back cover of
this book jacket
it depicts the three authors in front of
their vehicle
that they drove on their original 1941
tour of
mexican agriculture to determine whether
the u.s could impact food production
there
that survey trip ultimately ended up
being a spark that ignited the green
revolution what i love about it is that
the picture included one incredibly
lucky graduate student richard schulte's
who was invited along by professor
mangelsdorf
it intrigues me to imagine his version
of that historic trip
graduate students have a unique
perspective that i really value when
working on projects with them
on the right is a picture of this book
meaning more to me later in life while
using it to mentor the inaugural group
of the 2018
napb borlaug scholars with their mentors
you see as a friend of plant breeding i
understand the importance of plant
breeding passion
i know that most if not all of you
listening share the same passion for our
profession and our scientific craft
like ann marie you should look around
see things that need to be done and get
started
like her you should expect others to
join in and carry on the work
remember
you can have all the passion in the
world for something but if you never do
anything about it that patient passion
is useless
i will end with this
napb is a wonderful organization for
turning plant breeding passion into
actions
i make this statement because napb has
so many incredibly talented members
who are already deeply passionate about
plant breeding
we are doing great things we are doing
the right things
we can and should do more of the right
things
we are still a young organization we are
still growing in my opinion we're
growing too slowly
where is the sense of urgency where's
the fire in the belly the passion
in july of 2019 napb had
451 total members
in our strategic plan we set an
achievable goal of reaching 650 members
by 2023
that would have required gaining 40
members per year over the next five
years
we needed this level of growth to
support our grand goal of hiring our
first dedicated staff person
in july of 2021 we had 477
members
that is a net gain of 26 members in 24
months
surely we can do better than one new
member a month
now we need to make up for lost time
therefore i have an urgent challenge
for each one of you regarding 2022 napb
membership
hear me now
write this down
please set a personal goal of recruiting
at least one new napb member
who does not appear in our current
member directory
as any pb members you all have access to
our online directory
you can type in any name to see whether
your potential recruit is an active
member
this is a great opportunity to increase
our membership diversity
do not quit on this goal until you are
successful
this is key to napb growth in 2022
when that name of your recruit shows up
in our directory you can declare success
it is an easily attainable and
measurable goal
this is key to napb growth in 2022 and
beyond
make it a reoccurring annual goal
as you renew your membership annually
look around find a committee
and volunteer your services
please support our grand goal for hiring
our first napb staff member by 2023
your contributions to the napb general
fund will help drive this goal
now i would like to acknowledge and
personally thank our passionate four lug
scholars
for a successful fundraising
campaign this year
it was their idea and their effort thank
you
thank you to our generous borlaug
scholars donors and faithful sponsors
you are nurturing plant breeding passion
in a very direct way
i commend you all for your voluntary
actions and selfless service to napb
driven by your passion for plant
breeding you are all friends of plant
breeding
express your passion
with action
get her done
it's a great time to be a plant breeder